شكرا للزميل نادين تغطيتنا مستمره
مشاهدينا لليوم الثاني عشر على التوالي
للحرب في السودان ولليوم الثاني من ايام
الهدنه الهشه حيث تستمر المواجهات بين
الجيش والدعم السريع وسط اتهامات متبادله
بخرق الهدنه بيان للجيش قال ان الدعم
السريع نفذ قصفا مدفعيا عشوائيا لمناطق في
محيط القياده العامه واداره المرافق
الاستراتيجيه في البلاد فيما تتواصل او
فيما تواصل القناصه اطلاق النار في
المناطق المحيطه بمطار الخرطوم وحي المطار
السكني كذا في مناطق في بحري وام درمان في
حسب بيان للجيش الجيش ايضا رصد تحركات
كثيفه لارتال عسكريه قادمه من كوردوفان
ودارفور الى الخرطوم واتهم الجيش ايضا
قوات الدعم السريع باستمرار استخدام
المدنيين في الاحياء السكنيه دروعا بشريه
ومن جهتها حملت قوات الدعم السريع المجتمع
الدولي مسؤوليته تجاه خلق الهدنه من قبل
قيادات الجيش السوداني مشيره الى ان عدم
التزام قيادات الجيش بالهدنه تؤكد تعدد
مراكز القرار داخل الجيش كما اتهمت قوات
الدعم السريع قوات من الجيش بمهاجمه
مواقعها بمحيط القصر الجمهوري وارض
المعسكرات وسوبا في وقت واحد
هذا وقالت نقابه اطباء السوداني في بيانها
اليومي ان عدد الوفيات بين المدنيين ارتفع
الى
295 حاله وفاه بينما تم تسجيل
1790 حاله اصابه بين المدنيين منذ بدايه
الاشتباكات ذكرت النقابه ايضا ان هناك
العديد من الاصابات والوفيات غير مشموله
لعدم التمكن من الوصول للمستشفيات لصعوبه
التنقل والوضع الامني في البلاد
في رمضان كان عندنا
عشره
الى ام درمان مباشره يلتحق بنا من هناك
مراسل العربيه سالم الهاشمي سالم اهلا بك
معي في هذه التغطيه اريد السؤال اولا عن
تحليق طيران
وطائرات من نوع فوق ام درمان كيف تبدو
الصوره هل استهدفت هذه الطائرات ايا من
اهدافها في الارض
[موسيقى]
نعم سمعت اصوات هذه الطائرات وهي تحلق في
مناطق في جنوبي وجنوب غرب ام درمان كذلك
في مناطق متفرقه من تلك المناطق تستهدف
قوات الدعم السريعه المؤتمر في محيطة
لدعوه التلفزيون وكذلك القوات التي تتمركز
في المهندسين والتي تتبادل اطلاق النار مع
القوات المسلحه السودانيه هذا ابرز ما هو
واقع على الارض هناك في تلك المناطق لكن
ليس لدينا حتى الان تفاصيل عن استهداف هذه
الطائرات لكن بالحديث عن الوضع الاقتصادي
انا هنا في سوبر ماركت ومع قله وشحت
المواد الغذائيه وايضا مع قله وشحا المحل
التجاريه المفتوحه والتي تعمل وجدنا هذا
المكان وهو يعمل بطاقه جيده وعليه اقبال
الكثيف من المواطنين وايضا هو هنا ايضا
هذا المحل يرفع شعارا بانه لا يريد ان
يتحدث كما يفعل التجار من ارتفاع في
الاسعار معي مدير هذا المحل
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم وعليكم السلام ورحمه الله
وبركاته الله يكرمك الله يديك العافيه
الحمد لله
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والصلاه والسلام
على رسول الله نسال الله ان يتقبل
الشهدائنا وان يشفي الجرحى وربنا يرفع
مننا هذا البلاء ان شاء الله
والله الحمد لله احنا نحاول بقدر الامكان
ان نوفر الحاجات الاساسيه بالنسبه للمواطن
نحن الحمد لله في ام درمان شارع الوادي
هايبر ماركت الديزل بنحاول بقدر الامكان
نوفر الحاجات للمواطن معظم المواطن
الغذائيه يعني لكن واهم من ده كله احنا
نوفر الحاجات دي بنفس الاسعار القديمه
كانت قبل الاسماء يعني ما في طمع ما في
جشع والله يا اخي نحن حاليا بنحاول يعني
نوفر الحاجات دي من المخازن الموجوده
عندنا الحاجات اللي كانت موجوده السكر
موجود والدقيق موجود واللحوم برضو بنحاول
نوصلها بقطر الامكان يعني هسه حاليا في
الموقع هنا نحن ما عندنا حاجه لكن امدادات
ايوه امدادات المواد الغذائيه فيها شعح
والله الله اعلم ما اعرف لكن احنا الحاجات
الموجوده عندنا ان شاء الله نحاول بقدر
الامكان نوفره للمواطن بنفس الاسعار
القديمه اهم حاجه واحنا من هنا نوصي انه
كل التجار في الفتره دي يحاولوا بقدر الام
كان انه يوفروا للمواطن الحاجات دي كلها
بما يحتاجونها من مواد غذائيه اساسيه بنفس
الاسعار القديمه بنفس الاسعار بدون طمع
بدون جشع بدون يعني تجاره ازمات لانه دمعه
وقته والله يعني المواطن في حاجه للحاجات
دي في الوقت الحالي ده وهذا ما زمن طمع ان
شاء الله ربنا يصلح الحال والعباد ان شاء
الله
اذا كانت هذه هي الجوله سريعه هنا في هذا
المول او السوبر ماركت الذي يعمل بكل
تاكيد في ام درمان وعليه اقبال من
المواطنين في شراء المواد التي يحتاجونها
الان ايضا يعني وضعت هناك لافتات تتحدث
على انه لا للجشع ولا للتجاره تجاره
الازمات هذه اللافته التي يضعها هذا المحل
طيب سعر القديم
ويجتهد هنا اصحاب المحل بان يوفروا هذه
السلع لكنهم يشكون من الامداد بعد ان
تنتهي هذه المواد الموجوده حتى الان طيب
يعني في
وقت الازمات سالم يعني هناك من يشتري
بكميات كبيره للتخزين خوفا طبعا من
الايام القادمه وما ستحمله ايضا حتى كذلك
هل هناك من تنظيم معين فيما يخص هذه
النقطه في هذه المحاله التجاريه التي توفر
هذه المواد للمواطنين والمقيمين ايضا
سالم هل تسمعني
سالم
طيب يبدو ان زميل سالم لا يسمعني في هذه
اللحظات لكن هذه الصوره نقلها لنا ولا
تزال هذه الصوره معنا مشاهدينا على شاشه
العربيه من احد
المحال التجاريه واحد محل المواد الغذائيه
الكبيره ايضا في ام درمان العربيه ترصد
الاوضاع ايضا فيها مع ثاني ايام الهدنه
المعلنه قبل يعني
24 ساعه التي اعلنت بين الجيش والدعم
السريع تعرضت طبعا هذه الهدنه لعدد من
الخروقات العربيه موجوده في احد محل
المواد الغذائيه الكبيره في ام درمان ترصد
الوضع قبل قليل الزميل سالم الهاشمي كان
قد التقى بصاحب هذا
المحل ايضا كذلك
وبانه يبيع المواد الغذائيه بنفس الاسعار
التي كانت عليها قبل بدايه هذه
اشتباكات نتابع هذه الصور ايضا من محيط
مطار الخرطوم كما نشاهد الان في الصوره لا
تزال الاشتباكات
دائره بالقرب من مطار الخرطوم كان الجيش
السوداني قبل قليل قد اعلن بان قناصه
الدعم السريع مستمره في اطلاق النار بمطار
الخرطوم ايضا كذلك كان قد نقل مراسل
العربيه بان هناك تحليق لطائرات الجيش
السوداني في العاصمه الخرطوم وايضا كذلك
ام درمان لكن الجيش السوداني اكد بان هناك
قناصه للدعم السريع مستمره في اطلاق النار
بمطار الخرطوم وبالاضافه طبعا الى بحري
وام جرمان لكن هذه الصوره التي نشاهدها
الان من امام مدرج
للطائرات التي تربط في مطار الخرطوم وهو
المطار الذي شهد عدد من
الاشتباكات التي تقطعت
ثم عادت مره اخرى بين الجيش السوداني وقوه
الدعم السريع عطلت طبعا
عطل المطار منذ اليوم الاول للاشتباكات
بعد ان تم استهداف بعض الطائرات الموجوده
في مدرج الطيران ولا تحليق فوق الاجواء
السودانيه قبل الثلاثين من ابريل حسب ما
تم الاعلان عنه في السودان الجيش السوداني
لازال يتهم قناصه الدعم السريع بانهم
مستمرون في اطلاق النار بمحيط مطار
الخرطوم والذي نشاهد الان الصوره المباشره
من امامه كما نشاهد
الى عمليات الاجلاء تحديدا تواصل المملكه
العربيه السعوديه جهودها عبر موانئ جده في
البحر الاحمر لانقاذ الجاليات الاجنبيه
الهاربه من الحرب في السودان في هذا
السياق اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه ان
سفينه تقل
1687 مدنيا من اكثر من 50 دوله فروا من
العنف في السودان قد وصلت الى السعوديه
الاربعاء باكبر عمليه انقاذ من نوعها
تنفذها المملكه حتى الان وزاره الخارجيه
في بيان لها اكدت حرص المملكه على توفير
كامل الاحتياجات الاساسيه للرعايه الاجانب
تمهيدا لتسهيل مغادرتهم الى بلدانهم
قاعده الملك فيصل مشاهدينا البحريه في جده
ومنذ الساعات الاولى من فجر اليوم
الاربعاء على اوهباب لتنفيذ عمليات
الاجلاء
وكانت اول سفينه وصلت تحت حمايه القوات
البحريه السعوديه على متنها
1687 شخصا من ثمانيه وخمسين جنسيا سفينه
الاجلاء كانت تقل 13 سعوديا وسته واربعين
امريكيا واربعين بريطانيا واحد عشر
المانيين بالاضافه الى اربعه فرنسيين
و560 اندونيسيا
و239 يمنيا بالاضافه الى سته وعشرين تركيا
امامكم في الكاميرا عدد من الممثلين
والسفراء والدبلوماسيين لهؤلاء الرعايه
لاستقبالهم وانهاء كافه اجراءات سفرهم من
قبل الحكومه السعوديه ومن قبل ممثلينهم
بشكل كبير جدا خلال الفتره او خلال ساعه
الى ساعتين سوف يتم منها كافه اجراءات
السفر التابعه لهؤلاء الرعايه سوف تستمر
عمليه الانزال كما ذكرنا قبل قليل من ساعه
ونصف الى ساعتين ونصف سوف يتم انهاء
الاجراءات ونزولهم الى قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه ومن ثم الى مقرات السكن سوف يتم
استقبالهم بالاعلام وبالورود وبالحلوى كما
هو المعتاد نتحدث عن عمليات اجلاء استمرت
لمده ثلاثه ايام هذه هي السفينه او الموكب
الثالث والسفينه السادسه التي عملت على
نقل الرعايه من بورتسودان وسطه
قوات البحريه السعوديه ووزاره وبالتنسيق
مع وزاره الخارجيه والسفاره السعوديه في
الخرطوم وعدد كبير من قطعه الحكوميه التي
صخرت كافه جهدها للتعامل مع الرعايه او
التعامل مع ملف الرعايه واستقبالهم بشكل
كبير وبعمليات اجلاء مستمره منذ ثلاثه
ايام وحتى هذه اللحظه من المتوقع خلال
الساعات القادمه ان تكون هنالك رحلات
اجلاء قادمه من بورد سودان الى قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه سوف نستمر بتغطيه عمل
الملف والعمليات الاجلاء المستمره اللي من
قبل الحكومه السعوديه للرعايه الدول
الشقيقه والدول العربيه والدول الاجنبيه
الى بورسودان ومن بعد يعني مقامات المملكه
يعني بارك الله فيهم واخذنا بالعبارات
تقريبا الساعه سبعه الصباح غادرنا من
بورسودان والحين وصلنا اول المملكه الحمد
لله على سلامه الجميع مده اقامتنا تقريبا
سبع سنوات او اكثر شوي كنا مقيمين بمنطقه
بحري كافوري شو المعاناه والمشاهد اللي
انتم عشتوها في السودان اثناء الاشتباكات
يعني هو الرعب الطياره من فوقك كيف هيك عم
تقصف يعني رعب كان فظيع مذيعه يا محمد
معانا
يعني رعب نفسي وجسدي
والله كنا بالسودان بالعاصمه الخرطوم في
الخرطوم نفسها الخرطوم نفسه وكان في يعني
نسمع اصوات تقريبا كذا واخر فتره لما قلنا
انه خلص بدنا نطلع فكانت الضرب قوي جدا
يعني صراحه كان كل شيء منظم ما شاء الله
وكان كذا في جنود وكلهم قاعدين يعطونا
ترتيبات يعني فكان الموضوع جدا سهل الحمد
لله وصلتوا مع السفاره السعوديه هنا ايوه
اهلي من هنا تواصلوا معاهم قالوهم قالوا
لهم نروح على الميناء البري البحري
وجينا والحمد لله كل شيء كان سهل
ساهمت سفينه وامانه السعوديه باجلاء مئات
الاشخاص من مختلف جنسيات العالم مسجله
بذلك اكبر عمليه اجلاء من السودان حتى
الان نتعرف على امانه
سفينه امان السعوديه تقوم باكبر عمليه
اجلاء من السودان السفينه ترفع علم
السعوديه منذ 44 عاما
ايطاليه الصنع تملكها شركه نماء للتجاره
الدوليه عرضها يصل الى 23 مترا وطولها
لمئه وثمانيه واربعين مئات الرعايه
الاجانب استخدموها لتنقلهم من ميناء سواكن
الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه في جده
يصلون لوجهتهم المستقره وتغمرهم فرحه
النجاه يلوحون لها شكرا امانه على الامانه
هذا وقال قائم اعمال السفاره السودان لدى
السعوديه مهند عمر عباس في لقائه مع
العربيه ان هناك الاف العالقين بالسعوديه
لا يمكنهم العوده للسودان بسبب اغلاق مطار
الخرطوم مشيرا الى ان قوات الدعم السريع
تعمدت تعطيل مطار الخرطوم الدولي
كشف رئيس نادي طلاب الحضارم في السودان
ايمن الرئيس ان اكثر من 49 طالبا يمنيا لا
يزالون عالقين في سكن الطلاب بالخرطوم
بسبب المعارك الدائره بين قوات الجيش
والدعم السريع
طبعا قذيفه سقطت على بعد امتار يعني هذا
السكن طبعا الصوره وهذا موقع قديم يعني
عشرات الامتار فقط كانت تفصلنا عن كارثه
في السكن اللي في حاليا
49 نفس يعني هذا موقع السكن
هذا الموقع هنا في ارجاء هذه شارع المطار
ومعارفين في شارع المطار في الجهه هذه فيه
وراء الجهه المقابله في معسكرات ورق الجهه
اللي قدامنا هذه في هنا
معسكرة برضه للمخابرات وفي قوات يعني من
احد طرف الصرع مسيطره على المنطقه
جده الاسلاميه ينضموا الينا مراسل العربيه
نصفيان هاني مرحبا بك معي في هذه التغطيه
كنا نتابع معك منذ ظهر اليوم وصول
الفرقاطه الفرنسيه حتى هذه اللحظه هل وصلت
فرقاطات او سفن جديده الى ميناء جده ام لا
زال يتاهب قدوم هذه
الفرقاطات او السفن اليه
بالفعل نايف نعم العربيه تواكب اجلام او
عمليات الاجلاء التي تنفذها القوات
البحريه الملكيه السعوديه او كذلك
الفرقاطات والسفن من دول اخرى الى ميناء
جده الاسلامي او الى قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه وكذلك عمليات الاجلاء التي تتم
عبر الطيران الذي يصل الى قاعده الملك عبد
الله الجويه هنا في مدينه جده طبعا هناك
الاستعدادات والتاهب لاستقبال المزيد من
السفن والفرقاطات سواء الفرقاطات الحربيه
من دول عده او كذلك السفن التجاريه ايضا
سواء من ميناء جده الاسلامي او كذلك من
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه ولكن حتى هذه
اللحظه هي اخر هي اخر ما وصلت اليه
الفرقاطه الفرنسيه لورين وكذلك الان ايضا
اكتمل نزول كافه رعايه بعثه الامم المتحده
من هذه الفرقاطه التي تستعد الساعه
القادمه الى المغادره بعد ان يتم التاكد
ايضا من العمليات الاخرى لاجل مغادرتها من
رصيف ميناء جده الاسلامي طبعا هنا الامن
الصناعي في ميناء جده الاسلامي وكذلك
الاسعافات والمركبات الاسعافيه لحالات
الطوارئ
للركاب على متن هذه الفرقاطه كانت مستعده
وهي من قبل الميناء جده الاسلاميه وايضا
هناك الفرق وضباط وضباط الصف من حرس
الحدود التابعينا لوزاره الداخليه
السعوديه التي كانت ايضا لها جهود كبيره
في نهائي اجراءات سفره رعايه بعثه الامم
المتحده او كذلك الرعايه الجنسيه الاخرى
التي وصلت عبر السفن السعوديه
الان كنا نتابع قبل قليل يعني ربما مركبات
الاسعاف ايضا وهي تتاهب كذلك اريد السؤال
عن من وصل على متن هذه الفرقات الفرنسيه
هل هناك احد ممن وصل وا يعني كان يعاني من
اي اصابات او تعب او اعياء يعني ونقل بهذه
السيارات من خلال ما رصدت يعني من الحالات
الانسانيه
بالفعل بالفعل نعم هناك حالتين اصيبتا
بشظايا جراء عمليات القصف واما الحالات
الاخرى الاربعه هي ست حالات اجمالي ست
حالات اصابتين بشظايا ولكن الشظايا خفيفه
كانت في واحده في ساق احد رعايه بعثه
المتحده والاخرى كانت في اليد ولكن شظايا
بسيطه وتم استقبالها ايضا
والتوجه هذه الحالات الى مستشفى
او احدى مستشفيات مدينه جده طبعا الان ما
نشاهده ايضا هي الحافلات التي تقل رعايه
بعثه الامم المتحده الى مقر اقامتهم وايضا
هناك اكثر من 400 شخص
سوف يغادرون في هذه اللحظات من جده
الاسلامي وبينما ايضا في هذه اللحظات
تغادر هذه الحافلات سوف التقي بالاستاذ
محمد الغنيم وهو
عضو او احد اعضاء برنامج الاغذيه العالميه
مرحبا بك مره اخرى استاذ محمد الان ما هي
المرحله القادمه بالنسبه لرعايه بعثه
الامم المتحده المرحله القادمه الان
حيتحرك جميع
الاخوان من
موظفين الامم المتحده من هنا الى مطار
الملك عبد العزيز
بمشيئه الله الطائرات جاهزه لهم حاليا
بتقلع الطائرات بهم الى بلدانهم ان شاء
الله السالمين معافين يعني المغادرين
اليوم او الذين وصلوا اليوم سوف يغادرون
مباشره لن يكون هناك مقر اقامه لهم ابدا
ولا انتظار ولا نعم شكرا للسعوديه طيب ما
هي هل كنا نسمع ان هناك طائرات خاصه
وفرتها هناك طيران التجاري سوف يغادرون لا
اذا تم توفير طائرات خاصه من الامم
المتحده
بالتعاون
والسماح من من المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وهي متواجده الان في مطار الملك عبد
العزيز
جميع المخلين الان في الباصات يتجهون الى
الطائرات في مطار الملك عبد العزيز
ويقولون مباشره اذا سوف يقلعون هؤلاء رايه
بعثه الامم المتحده الى مطار الملك عبد
العزيز مباشره
باتجاه من ميناء جده الاسلامي باتجاه مطار
الملك عبد العزيز بحسب حديث الاستاذ محمد
غنيم وهو عضو البرنامج الاغذيه العالميه
سعود ايضا هناك سؤال ماذا عن الجنسيات هل
هناك عده جنسيات هل هناك سوف يتجهون الى
وجهه واحده دوله
هم جميع المخلين من عده جنسيات
لكن المعامله جميعا بتكون متساويه في
المطار وكل شخص موفر له المسار اللي
ارجاعها الى بلده بمعافى سليم ان شاء الله
التي سوف يغادرون لها كنا سمعنا عن بعض
الدول
في بعض الدول الافريقيه وفي بعض الدول
الاوروبيه نيروبي عنتاب وبعض الدول
الاوروبيه اللي مطلوبه بناء على الخطط
ماذا عن الدفعه الاخرى سمعنا ايضا ان هناك
اجمالي بعثه الامور المتحدهم قرابه الالف
شخص وصلوا اليوم 400
صحيح متبقي الدفعه الثانيه وان شاء الله
نحن بصدد التخطيط لاخلائهم في اقرب وقت
شكرا لك استاذ محمد اذا 400 شخص سوف
يتجهون مباشره الى مطار الملك عبد العزيز
الدولي غرب في مدينه جده في مدينه جده غرب
السعوديه وقد رصدنا قبل قليل ايضا الصور
الخاصه التي رصدتها العربيه من داخل احدى
الحافلات هنا لدينا اكثر من سبع حافلات
تقل اكثر من 400 شخص ايضا تبقى دفعه اخرى
لم تصل حتى الان وسوف تصل بحسب الاحاديث
الاستاذ محمد الغنيم ممثل برنامج الاغذيه
العالميه ان خلال الفتره القادمه بعد غد
سوف تصل الدفعه الثانيه عبر ايضا فرقه
عسكريه لم تحدد حتى الان ولكن ما نعلم ان
هناك فرقه طاقات وسفن تجاريه او فرقاطات
عسكريه وسفن تجاريه سوف تصل الى مدينه جده
سواء سوف تتوزع او سوف تتجه مباشره الى
ميناء جدا اسلامي او باتجاه قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه في ستصل اليوم هاني ام بعد
غدا ايضا مع هذه البعثه
المتبقيه من بعثه الامم المتحده الموجوده
في السودان
طبعا
سوف يكون هناك مغادره اولا هناك مغادره
الى العربيه ان سفينه
سوف يغادر
عن المواط
نين كانوا قد ادوا العمره في رمضان في شهر
رمضان سوف يغادرون اليوم لم يصلنا
بالتفصيل كم عددهم ولكن ان العدد سوف يكون
عدد كبير يوم امس غادر او خلال يومين
الماضيين غايدر اكثر من 2500 معتمر من جده
الى بورتو سودان اليوم سوف تغادر ايضا
دفعه اخرى ولكن لم يحدد العدد بعد سوف
نواكب ايضا ونقوم برصد عمليات مغادرتهم
عن عمليات الاجلاء من بورتو سودان الى
مدينه جده سوف مست وربما ايضا المساء تصل
سفينه اخرى الى مدينه جده قادمه من بورتو
السودان وسوف نحددها ان شاء الله في
النشرات القادمه تاكيد سنتابع معك هاني
الصفيان وايضا مع زميل سلطان السلمي وانتم
تتواجدان في ميناء جده وقاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه شكرا جزيلا لكم ميناء جدا مراسل
العربيه نصفيا
اذا خريطه المواجهات مشاهدينا في اليوم
الثاني لوقف اطلاق النار بين القوات
المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم السريع ما
زالت الاشتباكات مستمره في العاصمه
الخرطوم تحديدا في محيط القصر الرئاسي
ومناطق في محيط القياده العامه واداره
المرافق الاستراتيجيه التي تتعرض لقصف
مدفعي عشوائي وكذلك المناطق المحيطه بمطار
الخرطوم الدولي وحي المطار السكني ايضا
كذلك مناطق ايضا في بحري وام درمان وفق
الناطق الرسمي باسم القوات المسلحه
السودانيه بالاثناء تحدث الجيش السوداني
عن تحركات كثيفه لارتال عسكريه للدعم
السريع قادمه من كوردوفان ودارفور لتعزيز
قواتها بالخرطوم
ومع دخول عمليات الاجلاء من السوداني
يومها السادس واكبت كاميرا العربيه
العمليات في عده دول حيث يشهد مطار
بورتسودان الدولي الشرقي البلاد رحلات
اجلاء بواقع ثلاث رحلات جويه يوميا وعلى
متنها مئات الرعايه من الدول الاجنبيه
والبعثات الدبلوماسيه والموظفين الامميين
وبينما تتولد دفوعات وصلت احدى طائرات
الاجلاء الى بيروت بمساعده السعوديه محمله
ب 32 شخصا بينهم 12 فلسطينيين يحملون
اوراق اللبنانيه كما تمر عمليه الاجلاء
الى ليبيا عبر ثلاث مراحل بريه وجويه
وبحريه تبدا بالانتقال بالحافلات الى
بورتسودان ثم الترحيل الى ميناء جده وصولا
الى المحطه الاخيره والسفر بالطائره الى
طرابلس واستقبل مطار معيتيجا الدولي 105
من افراد الجاليه الليبيه في السودان بعد
اجلائهم بسبب الاشتباكات الدائره هناك
واكدت الجزائر ان 13 فلسطينيا واثنين
سوريا وعددا اخر من اعضاء السفاراتهم
بالخرطوم قدموا من مطار بورتسودان على متن
طائره عسكريه تابعه للجيش الوطني الشعبي
بدورها اعلنت هيئه الموانئ البريه في مصر
تجاوز القادمين من السودان الذين تمكنوا
من دخول البلاد عبر معبري قسطل وارقين
عشره الاف شخص وقالت في بيان لها ان
القادمين من السودان مع مختلف الجنسيه من
مع تكثيف العاملين في المبتدئين من اداره
الجوازات والجمارك وغيرها من الجهات
لاستيعاب الكثافه المتوقع
هذا وقال مسؤول في البحريه الامريكيه
لشبكه سي ان ان الولايات المتحده سترسل
سفينه حربيه ثالثه الى السودان تمتاز
بسرعه عاليه نسبيا وذلك بعد يوم واحد من
اعلان وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه ان وصول
سفينه للسواحل السودانيه وتوجه اخرى من
بحر العرب الى هناك واضاف المسؤول البحري
ان السفن الثلاثه قادره على نقل مئات
الاطنان من المعدات وعدد كبير من الافراد
بالسرعه عاليه نسبيا
وزاره الدفاع الالمانيه مشاهدينا كشفت ان
انتهت من عمليات الاجلاء من السودان موضحه
انها اكملت اجلاء نقلت خلاله اكثر من 700
شخص الى خارج السودان بينهم 200 مواطن
الماني
ينضم الينا الصحفي عبد القادر بكاش عبد
القادر مرحبا بك معي في هذه التغطيه
الموسعه على شاشه العربيه قبل قليل الزميل
هاني اصفيان كان يتحدث عن ان هناك سفينه
ستغادر من ميناء جده باتجاه بورتسودان تقل
ايضا كذلك حتى سودانيين كانوا قد انتهوا
من العمره في شهر رمضان لكن مع الاشتباكات
في السودان تعثر تعثرت عودتهم الى هناك
كيف هي الاستعدادات لاستقبالهم في
بورتسودان والاجراءات التي ستتخذ عبد
القادر
بحمد الله تمت طبعا السفينه القادمه اليوم
من جده هي الدعم المعتمرين كانوا عالغين
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه بعد اداء
العمره
وسيصلون الى ميناء بورسلان باذن الله
تعالى ومنها ان شاء الله
نفس السفينه عدد كبير من رعايه الدول
العربيه والاجنبيه الى ميناء جده من
بورسودان الان في مدينه برشلونه توجد
اربع بارجات حربيه عسكريه في موانئ
بورسودان الان تربط داخل المرابط منها
حربيه سعوديه وقطعه حربيه هنديه
صينيتان يتم الان
العمل في
صعود عدد من الرعايه دول متعدده اجنبيه
وعربيه الى البارجه السعوديه من بينهم
السفير اللبنانيه
ومن المتوقع ايضا
صعود عدد كبير من السنين على مصنع
البارجات الصينيتين ان شاء الله بالميناء
الاخضر وايضا الان تم الشحن 250 شخص
تقريبا على جثه حربيه هنديه تتجه باذن
الله الى ميناء جده جمله من تم اجلائهم
حتى اليوم من ميناء بورسودان الى ميناء
من شخص من خمسه وستين دوله
عبد القادر
طيب يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال بالزميل عبد
القادر بسبب طبعا يعني سوء ربما الاتصالات
ترد الاتصالات ايضا شبكه الهاتف
المتنقل والانترنت في السودان منذ بدايه
هذا اصير عسى نحاول العوده
للزميل عبد القادر وهو الذي ذكر بان عدد
من تم اجلائهم من ميناء بورتسودان باتجاه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه بلغ
2148 تحدث ايضا بان هناك مئتين وخمسين
شخصا صعدوا على اماكن الفرقاطه
الهنديه وبان هناك قطعه حربيه سعوديه
متواجده في بورت سودان وقطعتين ايضا
صينيتان في ذات
الرصيف البحري في بورسودان سنحاول العوده
اليه حلم جهز هذا الاتصال
نقف الشان السوداني جدل متصاعد مشاهدينا
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
حياله فراري سجناء من سجن كوبر المركزي
الجدل تركز اكثر على حقيقه هروب الرئيس
السابق عمر البشير ردا على ذلك اكد الجيش
السوداني ان الرئيس السابق عمر البشير لا
يزال محتجزا بمستشفى عسكري تحت حراسه
الشرطه القضائيه وقال في بيان له ان
البشير وعدد من قيادات حزبه محتجزون في
مستشفى علي العسكري عبر عن رفضه لاي
محاولات لربط ما يجري في السودان
بمزايدات على او في السجون بمزايدات على
مواقفه الوطنيه واوصف الجيش السوداني
الدعم السريع وقائده بانهم ربيبه العهد
البائد
الجيش السوداني مشاهدينا كان
قد اتهم قوات الدعم السريع بالوقوف وراء
العمليه وقال في بيان له ان سلطه اداره
السجون خارج نطاق اختصاصه وتقع تحت
مسؤوليه وزاره الداخليه واشار الجيش الى
انه لا مصلحه له في خروج النزلاء من
سجونهم بهكذا طريقه التي تضع امن الناس
وطمانينتهم على المحك مضيفا انه غير معني
باي بيانات تصدر من اي جماعه او افراد
خرجوا من السجون
اما شرطه السودانيه فحملت قوات الدعم
السريع مسؤوليه اطلاق سراح السجناء
بالاضافه الى الجرائم المرتكبه بحق
المواطنين واكدت الشرطه ان الدعم السريع
اطلق سراح النزلاء في سته سجون بالخرطوم
والولايات الشرطه قالت ايضا ان قوه الدعم
السريع اقتحمت سجنه كوبر وتسبب في مقتل
وجرح عدد من قوات الشرطه
وبالحديث عن سجن كوبر الذي غادرت منه
قيادات من نظام البشير ابرزهم احمد هارون
هذا السجن يقع في منطقه بحري بالعاصمه
الخرطوم يبعد عن المستشفى العسكري نحو
عشره كيلو مترات اي حوالي سبعه عشره دقيقه
بالسياره بحسب الجيش السوداني يرقد الرئيس
السابق البشير في المستشفى العسكري تحت
رقابه امنيه قبل اندلاع الاشتباكات
المستشار السياسي لقائد قوات الدعم السريع
يوسف عزت اتهم قيادات المواليه للبشير في
الجيش باطلاق سراح قيادات النظام السابق
من سجن كوبر واضاف في تصريحات للعربيه ان
مغادره قيادات نظام البشيري للسجن كان
امرا متوقعا
اليوم الاول لانقلاب الحركه الاسلاميه
الذي يدبره على كرتي نتوقع كل هذا العناصر
الاسلاميه داخل الجيش انا لا اتهم كل
الجيش الجيش ليس كله حركه اسلاميه هنالك
ضباط شرفاء ولكن هنالك جهاد داخل
الاستخبارات العسكريه هنالك جهات الضباط
اسلاميين ساهموا في اطلاق سراحه هذه
المجموعه او نحن لدينا معلومات من داخل
السجن لحظه اطلاق النار لحظه اقتحام السجن
لحظه اطلاق سراحهم ولكن كانت قواتنا لم
تكن قريبه من الموقع
للسيطره على هذه العمليه
وهنبقى في الجدل المصاحب لهروب قياداتهم
من نظام البشير من سجن كوبر حيث اكد
المستشار السياسي لقائد قوات الدعم السريع
للعربيه انما مسؤوليه الدعم السريع القاء
القبض على الرئيس المخلوع عمر البشير
واحمد هارون بعد عمليه اجلائهم من السجن
انا لا ليس لدي معلومه عن كيفيه تنفيذ
العمليه او كيفيه اخلاقه من السجن اؤكد لك
هذا هذا مجرد توقعات او احتمالات او
لاشخاص فيهم احمد هارون يوم عبد الرحيم
محمد
الشعب السوداني طوال 30 سنه نحن من
مسؤوليتنا وفي اطار حربنا
والتي يواجهوننا بها من مسؤوليتنا سنسعى
بكل ما يمكن
القبض عليه
اقدم سجنا في السودان افتتح عام
1903 يقع في حي كوبر بمدينه بحري قرب
النيل الازرق نسبت اسمه الى الجنرال
البريطاني كوبر الذي تولى اداره السجن
مساحته 5000 متر مربع وتصميمه يحاكي سجون
بريطانيا يضم محكومين سياسيين وجنائيين
وشهد اشهر اعدامات الضباط 14 قسما من
بينها قسم مخصص للمدانين باحكام الاعدام
وقسم لاصحاب السوابق واخر لذوي الاحكام
الطويله والقصيره وقسم للمعتقلين
السياسيين كان يضم الرئيس السابق البشير
وعددا من قيادات نظامه غادره عدد من
قيادات نظام البشير على خلفيه تدهور
الامني في البلاد
من هو احمد هارون القيادي في نظام الرئيس
السابق السوداني عمر البشير الذي خرج من
سجن كوبر والذي ابدى استعداده مع اخرين
للمتول امام القضاء
احمد هارون
من مواليد عام
1965 بمدينه الاوبيض
ينتمي لقبيله عربيه من شمال كردوفان
درس القانون بجامعه القاهره وتخرج عام
عاد الى السودان ليعمل في السلك القضائي
قاضيا
من العناصر البارزه في الحركه الاسلاميه
السودانيه
تم تعيينه وزيرا للشؤون الاجتماعيه في
ولايه جنوب كردفان
عين وزير الدوله في الداخليه عام 2003 بعد
ارتفاع وتيره التمرد في اقليم دارفور
اختلف مع قائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد
حمدان دقلو ما جعل الرئيس البشير يتدخل
للصلح بينهما
دخلنا في المشاكل وجاب لنا صنع البطاله
احمد هارون يا اخي احنا ما ملائكه 6000
تراس هارون لجنه امن دارفور التي تتهمها
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه بتجنيد وتسليح
الجنجويد وارتكاب انتهاكات واسعه
عين واليا لجنوب كردفان ومن ثم واليان
لشمال كردفان
طيب نعود مره اخرى الى بورتودان من هناك
ينظموا الينا الصحفي عبد القادر بكاش
مرحبا بك معي من جديد كنت قبل قليل تتحدث
عن
فرقاتتان صينيتان موجوده في ميناء
بورسودان بالاضافه طبعا الى فرقاطه سعوديه
وكذلك الى عدد من السفن التجاريه التي
يعني ترسو بالقرب من رصيف بورتسودان ان
كانت من معلومات وارقام لديك تجمل لنا عبد
القادر تفضل
الى ميناء جده خلال سته ايام من الاجلاء
التي تلتزم مدينه بورسلان هذا العمل يتم
بالتنسيق بين السلطات السودانيه والسعوديه
وتعطي اشراف مباشر من لجنه تم تكوينها من
الجانب السوداني ولجنه سعوديه يشرف عليها
السيد السفينه عدد من مساعديه بشكل مباشر
طيب الان نحن نتحدث كما ذكرت عن اربع
بوارج حربيه موجوده في ميناء بورت السودان
متى وكيف ستتحرك ايضا هل ستتحرك جميعها
الى ميناء جده والى قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه في جده ام ستتوجه الى اماكن اخرى
عبد القادر
البارجه السعوديه والهنديه ستتجهان باذن
الله الى
جده الباريات الصينيه في تاريخ عائلتي
مباشره مع علمتها
والان عمليات الاجراء التملي بشكل منتظم
حتى الان لم تواجه اي اشكاليه لاي من
الرعايه الباصره السعوديه تعمل عدد كبير
من الجنسيات المتعدده من بينهم سفينه
لبنان ستكون ان شاء الله اخر لبنانيين
المغادرين اليوم على مبنى السفينه الحربيه
السعوديه
بالحديث عن يعني الشخصيات الدبلوماسيه
ايضا والبعثات ان كانوا سفراء او يعني
احد من يعمل في القنصليات للدول الاجنبيه
في السودان هل
مازال هناك من ينتظر اجلائه من ميناء
بورتسودان حسب ممارسات عبد القادر
نعم نعم هناك عدد من المنظمات لا يزال
عمليه الاجلاء مستمره لموظفين الامويين
وكذلك يوجد بمدينه اليوم حوالي 35 من
بينهم السفير المغربي سيغادر اليوم اربع
سفراء عرب سيكونوا مقيمون ان شاء الله في
مدينه بورسلان خلال الايام القادمه
للاطمئنان على عمليات الرعايه العرب
والاجانب كم عدد من تبقى من السفراء اذا
اذا سمحت
ومن غير العرب
من غير العرب
[موسيقى]
كنت تريد ان تضيف معلومه ايضا كذلك
توجد مدينه ب
امري من جده وقيادات الان مقيمه في مدينه
بورسودان السيد
فولكس وعدد من
بعثته موجودون في برشلونه
موجود في في بورت سودان
سيغادر يعني
لن يغادر طبعا
قادر اسرته فقط طيب
ايضا ايضا غادر 35 من الشاشه السودانيين
من حمله الجوازات المزدوجه الى ميناء جده
في عدد من الرحلات خلال السته ايام
الماضيه ابرزهم وزير الخارجيه السابق عمر
الدين كم عدد يعني كان هناك من ارقام او
معلومات متوفره لديك عبد القادر عن عدد
ربما البوارج البحريه العسكريه التي ستصل
الى ميناء بورتسودان وستقل طبعا ربما
مواطنيها او مواطني دول صديقه لها او ايضا
حتى سفن تجاريه ايضا تقوم بذات المهام عبد
القادر
السفينه التجاريه الوحيده تعمل في الخط
الالهي جده بورسلان هي تطبع لشركه نمى
المثليه وهي سفينه تسمى الامانه وليست
هناك اي سفن تجاريه اخرى
باقيات حربيه لدول متعدده وتاتي بشكل اجري
نسبه لظروف الاستثنائيه لم يتسنى لنا
معرفه جدول غدوه ومتى الان لكن هناك ضوارج
يعني بارده فرنسيه غادرت امس ومن المتوقع
وصولها غدا الى مدينه برشلونه مره اخرى
لاجلاء بعض الرعايه جميع السفن حتى الان
اغلب 90% من السفن المرتجعه المتحركه من
بورسودان لاجراء الرعايه تتجه نحو ميناء
جده وميناء الفيتر اشكرك جزيل الشكر من
بورت سوداني الصحفي عبد القادر باكاش على
كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل من بورت سودان
القيادي في قوه الحريه والتغيير ياسر
عرمان قال ان بيان قيادات البشير بعد
مغادرتهم لسجن كوبر هو دعوه لتوسيع نطاق
الحرب علمان اضاف انه يجب شد الانفس لوقف
الحرب وليس لتوسيعها مشيرا الى ان البيان
يتعارض مع ما يريده السودانيون والقوه
الاقليميه والمجتمع الدولي
اما قوه الحريه والتغيير فتاهمت نظام
الرئيس السابق عمر البشير بالوقوف في وراء
الحرب الدائره في البلاد وقالت في بيان
لها ان بيان احمد هارون يؤكد ان النظام
البائد هو من يقف وراء الحرب الحاليه
واضافت ان مخطط من وصفتها بالفولول سيقود
البلاد للانهيار اذا ادعت شعبنا الشعب
السوداني للتصدي لهب واشار البيان الى ان
الطريق الوحيد لمعالجه التشوهات الامنيه
التي تشهدها البلاد هو الحلول السياسيه
قيادات نظام البشير يغادرون سجن كوبر الى
جهه امنه
الفارون قالوا انهم سيؤمنون الحمايه
لانفسهم ابرز هؤلاء الوزير الاسبق احمد
هارون عينه البشير منسقا عاما للشرطه
الشعبيه اتهم بارتكاب جرائم حرب في دارفور
عندما كان يشغل منصب وزير الدوله علي
عثمان طه البرلماني والوزير السوداني
الاسبق شغل حقيبتي التخطيط والخارجيه ثم
نائبا اولا للرئيس عمر البشير رجل الامني
نافع علي نافع مدير جهاز الامن العام
والامن الخارجي شغل منصبه وزير الزراعه
ومساعدا للبشير حينا وزيرا لديوان الحكم
الاتحادي ونائبا لرئيس حزب المؤتمر الوطني
الحاكم رجل الاقتصاد عوض الجاز شغل حقائب
وزاريه منها التجاره والطاقه وشؤون الدوله
تنسب اليه تهم بالفساد واداره اموال
الحركه الاسلاميه في الخارج ابراهيم
السنوسي مساعد البشير ورئيس مجلس شورى حزب
المؤتمر الشعبي يتهم السنوسي بانه احدى
الشخصيات المشاركه في انقلاب
1989 الذي جاء بالبشير الى السلطه
مشاهدينا نذكر بالتطورات الميدانيه في
السودان حيث تستمر المواجهات بين الجيش
والدعم السريع وسط اتهامات متبادله بخرق
الهدنه بيان للجيش قال ان الدعم السريع
نفذ قصفا مدفعيا عشوائيا لمناطق في محيط
القياده العامه
وفي اداره المرافق الاستراتيجيه بالبلاد
فيما تتواصل
او فيما تواصل القناصه اطلاق النار في
مناطق المحيطه بمطار الخرطوم وحي المطار
السكني ومناطق في بحري وام دربان بحسب
بيان الجيش السوداني الجيش كذلك رصد
تحركات كثيفه لارتاء العسكريه قادمه من
كردوفان ودارفور الى الخرطوم الجيش كذلك
اتهم قوات الدعم السريع باستمرار استخدام
المدنيين في الاحياء السكنيه
دروعا بشريه
ومن جهتها ايضا مشاهدينا حملت قوات الدعم
السريع المجتمع الدولي الدولي مسؤوليته
تجاه خرق الهدنه من قبل قيادات الجيش
السوداني مشيره الى ان عدم التزام قيادات
الجيش بالهدنه تؤكد تعدد مراكز القرار
داخل الجيش كما اتهمت قوات الدعم السريع
بمهاجمه مواقعها بمحيط القصر الجمهوري
وارض المعسكرات وسوبا في وقت واحد
ومعنا من معبر اركين على الحدود المصريه
السودانيه مراسل العربيه احمد عثمان احمد
مرحبا بك معي في هذه التغطيه المباشره على
شاشه العربيه كيف تبدو الصوره في معبر
اركين الاجلاء ايضا من هذا المعبر الى مصر
الكثافه فيه ايضا
مرحبا نايف يعني كما ذكرت هناك تدفق لعبور
كثير من المصريين والسودانيين والجنسيات
الاخرى يعني بيان لهيئه الموانئ المصريه
اكد بان حتى الساعات الاخيره تم عبور اكثر
من عشره الاف من المعبرين معبر ارجين حيث
اقف حيث كان هناك حوالي
800,700 شخص عبروا خلال الايام الماضيه
وايضا المعبر الاخر وهو معبر القسطل والذي
كان في حدود اكثر من 1300 هذه الارقام
يعني هناك تفاوت فيما يتعلق بمعبر اربيجين
هناك ساعات يكون هناك فيها خروج مكثف لبعض
المصريين والسودانيين ومن ثم هناك حاله من
الهدوء ثم هناك ساعات اخرى مع المساء ربما
تزيد نسب الذين يخرجون من هذا المعبر يعني
حتى الان هناك بعض يعني الذين يتحدثون بان
هناك
تاخر لبعض الوقت فيما يتعلق
البقاء لفتره طويله في المعبر في الجزء
السوداني او الجانب السوداني من المعبر
وهناك عمليات التدقيق المعتاده والتفتيش
فيما يتعلق بالمعبر الجانب المصري مصري من
جهتها ربما في محاوله الاستيعاب هذا الضغط
والتدفق من قبل القادمين او النازحين من
السودان اكثرت من الموظفين العاملين سواء
في هذا المعبر في اريجين او في معبر خاصه
في محاوله لتسهيل عمليات الخروج خلال
الايام الماضيه والايام المقبله حتى الان
نفس الحديث نايف الذي نسمعه من قبل الذين
يخرجون من هذا المعبر يرون لنا ساعات
الرعب والقلق التي التي هذه الساعات التي
تم معايشتها في السودان خلال الساعات
الاخيره ايضا يعني هناك حاله من القلق
التي تسيطر عليهم فيما يتعلق بمستقبل
الوضع خلال الايام المقبله هل احمد اذا
اذا سمحت يعني فقط اريد التحقق للتذكير
بهذه الاخبار العاجله الان على شاشه
العربيه كما نشاهد بيان للجيش السوداني
يقول بان مجموعات من الدعم السريع تهاجم
الان مقر القياده العامه بالعاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم اذا الجيش السوداني
مشاهدينا في بيان له يقول بان مجموعات من
الدعم السريع تهاجم الان مقر القياده
العامه بالخرطوم كان قد شهد محيط القياده
العامه بالخرطوم خلال الايام الاثنت عشر
الماضيه يعني كرا وفرا في محيطه بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع الجيش
السوداني يضيف في البيان بانه يتصدى
لمجموعات الدعم السريع التي تهاجم القياده
العامه وتكبدهم خسائر كان الجيش قد اعلن
ايضا هذا اليوم بان هناك قناصه من قوات
الدعم السريع يتمركزون بالقرب من المناطق
حيويه في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
تحديدا مطار الخرطوم الان الجيش السوداني
يقول بانه يتصدى لمجموعات من الدعم السريع
تهاجم القياده العامه وتكبدهم ايضا كذلك
خسائر كما نشاهد في العاجل اسفل الشاشه
امامنا الان
قناصه الدعم السريع كما ذكرنا
استمروا باطلاق النار بمحيط مطار الخرطوم
كما ذكر الجيش عاد الجيش ليذكر مره اخرى
او يعني يعطي بيانا جديدا بانه يتصدى
لمجموعات الدعم السريعه التي تهاجم
القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه السودانيه
والتي ذكرنا وتكبدهم خسائر طبعا والتي
ذكرنا بان ريحه ربما المواجهات تدور بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع حول
محيط هذه المنطقه القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه منذ بدايه هذه الاشتباكات
والاحتراف بين الجيش السوداني القوات
الدعم السريع الجيش السوداني في بيانه قال
بان مجموعات الدعم السريع تهاجم في هذه
اللحظات مقر القياده العملي القوات
المسلحه
بالعاصمه الخرطوم هذه الصوره التي نشاهدها
واياكم على شاشه العربيه الان هي الصور
حيه ومباشره للعاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
التي تشهد نزاعا واحترابا واشتباكات
متقطعه بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع منذ 12 منذ 12 يوما لا تزال يعني
عمليات الكرو والفرد من الجانبين
ومحاوله استهداف مناطق حيويه من قبل قوات
الدعم السريع بقناصتها طبعا التي تنتشر
حول مطار الخرطوم والتي ذكر الجيش
السوداني
بانها تستمر في اطلاق النار بمحيط الخرطوم
كنا قد شاهدنا واياكم مشاهدينا على مدار
الايام الماضيه يعني اشتباكات متقطعه حول
مقر القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه سماع
دائم لذوي اطلاق الرصاص والانفجارات حول
هذه المنطقه وهي التي تعرضت الى القصف
اكثر من مره محاوله استهداف ايضا
للقياده العامه بالخرطوم من قبل مجموعات
الدعم السريع في هذه اللحظات كما يشير
الجيش السوداني اذا في بيانه امامنا على
شاشه العربيه الان الجيش السوداني يؤكد
بانه يتصدى لكل مجموعات الدعم السريع التي
تحاول ان تهاجم القياده العامه كان طبعا
مراسل العربيه قد نقل لنا قبل يعني ساعه
من الان بان هناك تحليق لطائرات الجيش
السوداني تحديدا في العاصمه الخرطوم وكذلك
امم درمان هذه هي الصوره التي ننقلها الان
مباشره من مطار الخرطوم وهو طبعا وهي
المنطقه الحيويه التي عطلت منذ اليوم
الاول لهذه الاشتباكات بعد ان تم استهداف
مدرج المطار الذي تربط فيه بعض الطائرات
التجاريه التابعه لدول اقليميه وتعرضت
طبعا
لاستهداف في مدرج المطار ما ادى الى تعليق
الرحلات من والى مطار الخرطوم الدولي
سودانيون سائقي الحافلات بزياده اسعار
تذاكر السفر من الخرطوم الى ولايات اكثر
امانا الامر الذي اثار غضب واستياء
الاهالي واعتبر الكثير من السودانيين
الامر استغلالا واضحا من قبل السائقين
لكسب المال رغم الظروف الصعبه التي تمر
بها البلاد بسبب المعارك المندلعه في
مدنها بين قوات الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع
استغلال ذاته بشر من اصحاب الاوساط
ويعني التذكره الصباح بسعر والنسب بسعر
وبعد باكر بيسعد عن الصباح الليله
350 اسوان
القاهره ب 400 الف
مراسله العربي حين كانت قد رصدت الاجواء
في منطقه المعموره جنوب الخرطوم حيث يحاول
المواطنون وبعض الاجانب مغادره العاصمه
هربا من المعارك
نمشي مصر
[موسيقى]
في العيش بقى فيه اي حاجه حتى الاندومي
الحاجه البسيطه
في الشارع من بيتنا الثاني داخله على شقتي
الرصاص
الدعامه بنص الحله الرصاص تحت العينه يعني
امام معدوم كده
مسافرين الاسره كلها
بمسابقه 300 في الميه او اكثر
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات